>> Greg: PRESIDENT BIDEN
LOOKING PRETTY FOOLISH AFTER
BOASTING RIGHT BEFORE CHRISTMAS
THAT HE HAD ENDURED AT THE
SUPPLY CHAIN CRISIS.
>> President Biden: OF THE
MUCH PROTECTED CRISIS DIDN'T
OCCUR.
PACKAGES ARE MOVING.
GIFTS ARE BEING DELIVERED.
SHELVES ARE NOT EMPTY.
>> Greg: TRY TELLING THAT TO
AMERICANS POSTING PHOTOS OF
EMPTY STORES AND THE HASHTAG
BEAR SELVES.
LOCAL MEDIA OUTLETS ALSO
REPORTING THAT PEOPLE CAN FIND
CERTAIN PRODUCTS WHEN THEY GO
SHOPPING.
I KNOW JESSE HAS HAD A HECK OF A
TIME FINDING MOST, BUT WE ARE
WORKING ON IT.
JESSIE, I'M GOING TO SOUND LIKE
A RED MEAT DELIVERYMAN BUT ONLY
A DEMOCRAT COULD CREATE SCARCITY
AND THE MOST ABUNDANT COUNTRY
WE'VE EVER SEEN IN THE HISTORY
OF THE WORLD.
WHY DOES THIS ONLY HAPPEN WHEN
THERE ARE DEMOCRATS?
>> Jesse: I LOVE RED MEAT AND
AM GLAD YOU ASKED THAT QUESTION.
WHAT HAPPENED IS EVERYONE CAUGHT
THE CHRONICLE OVER CHRISTMAS,
THEY GOT BACK TO WORK, TESTED
POSITIVE IN THEIR BOSS MADE HIM
QUARANTINE FOR FIVE TO TEN DAYS.
THOUSANDS OF THESE PEOPLE WERE
CONFUSED SUPPLY AND DISTRIBUTION
AND THAT'S WHY YOU ARE SEEING A
LOT OF EMPTY SHELVES ON THE
STORE AND ITS CREATING SCARCITY.
IT CREATES A FEAR FACTOR BECAUSE
PRICES ARE GOING UP AND THAT
THERE IS ECONOMIC ANXIETY
BECAUSE PEOPLE CAN'T AFFORD IT
AND JOE JUST ISN'T TETHERED TO
THAT ECONOMIC ANXIETY, THE RISE
AND THE COST OF LIVING.
THAT'S WHY HE'S GETTING HAMMERED
RIGHT NOW AND I MYSELF HAVE
SUFFERED FROM EMPTY STORE
SHELVES.
WE SHOP WHERE WE GET THE
GROCERIES DELIVERED AND TO
MAXIMIZE EFFICIENCY.
THE WOMAN FROM THE GROCERY STORE
CALLED ME AT SAID MR. WATER IS,
WE DON'T HAVE THE
BONE-IN RIBEYE, WE ONLY HAVE THE
BONELESS RIBEYE AND I SAID FINE.
IT'S NOT THE SAME.
AND THEN SHE SAID, MR. WATERS,
WE DON'T HAVE THE HICKORY SMOKED
BACON, WE ONLY HAVE THE
APPLEWOOD.
AND I'M LIKE, NOW I'M GETTING
NERVOUS.
SHE SAID FINALLY, MR. WATERS, WE
HAVE JUST RUN OUT OF THAT
CHICKEN LIVER PATE.
ARE WE LIVING IN VENEZUELA?
I MEAN WHAT ARE WE DOING HERE,
PEOPLE?
>> Greg: JESSE, YOU TRULY ARE
A FIRST RESPONDER WHEN IT COMES
TO GOURMET FOOD BECAUSE YOU ARE
THERE WHEN WE LEARN ABOUT THE
SHORTAGES.
YOU ARE DOING GOD'S WORK.
YOU KNOW, DEGEN, THE PROBLEM --
JESSE BROUGHT UP THE POINT THAT
BIDEN IS UNTETHERED TO THIS
BUT HE WAS SOLD TO SS POLITICAL
XANAX.
WE DID FOUR YEARS OF METH TRUMP
AND IT WE ARE SUPPOSED TO RELAX
NOW THAT WE GOT JOE BIDEN.
AND HE SAID HE'S NOT CALL HIM,
HE IS UNTETHERED TO THE ANXIETY.
HE'S OBLIVIOUS TO WHAT WE ARE
GOING THROUGH AND HE THOUGHT
THAT WOULD BE CALMING BUT IT'S
ACTUALLY THE OPPOSITE.
>> Dagen: AND HE DOESN'T EVEN
TRY TO HIDE THE FACT THAT HE'S
COMPLETELY DISCONNECTED FROM
REALITY.
WHO TOLD HIM ABOUT THE HIGH
PRICE OF MEAT?
SOMEBODY TOLD ME THAT YOU
COULDN'T GET THE BACON AT THE
STORE.
IT IS A HARDSHIP, NOT AN
INCONVENIENCE OR MOST AMERICANS,
AND TOMORROW MORNING WE LOOK AT
THE CONSUMER PRICE INDEX FOR
DECEMBER.
IT'S GOING TO BE 7%
YEAR-OVER-YEAR, THE HIGHEST IN
40 YEARS.
MY STORE CELLS ARE BARE BECAUSE
OF THIEVERY ON SHOPLIFTING, NOT
BECAUSE OF SUPPLY SHORTAGES.
BUT I WILL TELL YOU THAT
JAY POWELL, HEAD OF THE
FEDERAL RESERVE HAS COME OUT AND
SAID IT IN A SENSE, I
PARAPHRASE, I'M NOT PLAYING YOUR
REINDEER GAMES ANYMORE.
THEY ARE GOING TO START TYPING
MONETARY POLICY.
THEY WON'T BE BUYING ANY MORE
TREASURY DEBT, THEY'VE BEEN
SOPPING UP MORE THAN HALF THE
TREASURY DEBT ISSUED BY THESE
SPENDTHRIFT DEMOCRATS AND THEY
WILL START RAISING INTEREST
RATES BECAUSE INFLATION IS A
CONCERN.
IT'S THAT $9 TRILLION BALANCE
SHEET.
HE'S FIGHTING INFLATION,
JAY POWELL.
BUT IT'S GOING TO GET UGLY FOR
JOEY AND COMPANY.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW GERALDO,
THERE'S NOTHING WRONG WITH
SAYING, THIS, TOO, SHALL PASS.
BUT THAT'S NOT A STRATEGY, IT'S
A COMFORT.
IT SEEMS LIKE THAT'S BIDEN'S
ONLY THING, LIKE THIS WILL
HAPPEN AND EVERYTHING WILL BE
FINE BUT, THE ONLY THING IS
PASSING HIS GAS.
>> Geraldo: [LAUGHS]
ASIDE FROM THE FLATULENCE, I
THINK THAT THIS, TOO, SHALL
PASS.
BIDEN IS UNLUCKY.
HE DIDN'T EXPECT THE COUNTRY TO
BE THE SUCCESSFUL ECONOMICALLY
SPEAKING.
HE DIDN'T EXPECT PEOPLE
RECOVERING FROM BEING COOPED UP
FOR A COUPLE OF YEARS TO WANT TO
SPEND MONEY, EVEN AS PRICES WERE
GOING UP.
PEOPLE STILL WANTED TO BUY AND
DEMAND IS STILL INTENSE.
AND I THINK THAT IS ULTIMATELY A
GOOD THING, UNEMPLOYMENT JUST
3.9%.
HE SHOULD REALLY BE SINGING THE
VIRTUE OF AN ECONOMY THAT'S
COMING AND I THINK THAT POWELL
AND THE FAT GUYS WILL CONTROL
INFLATION IN THE NEXT QUARTER OR
SO.
I'M NOT FRIGHTENED BY IT, I
THINK THAT BY OURSELVES NOW WILL
MEAN ABUNDANT SHELLS IN A COUPLE
OF WEEKS.
>> Greg: WHAT DO YOU SAY TO
THAT, DANA?
>> Dana: WE SHOULD ALL BE SO
LUCKY.
I WILL TELL YOU, I WAS A VICTIM
OF THE BEAR CELLS.
NOT SO MUCH.
BUT WHEN I DIDN'T FEEL WELL OVER
CHRISTMAS, MY MOM SAID IT YOU
NEED TO GET CLORE SEPTIC SPRAY.
SO PETER GOES OUT AND GOES TO
ALL THE STORIES, THERE'S NO COLD
MEDICINE.
THE ONLY THING THEY HAD FOR A
SORE THROAT WAS LIKE A SPRAY FOR
CHILDREN, SO I GOT THAT.
AND I ENDED UP PASSING IT ON TO
THE FRITZ FAMILY BECAUSE, IT
WASN'T VERY GOOD.
>> Greg: IT ALWAYS COMES BACK
TO THE FRITZ.
>> Dana: WHILE I ONLY HAVE TEN
SECONDS SO I BRING IT UP.
>> Greg: I WENT TO THE
FURNITURE STORE AND YOU KNOW
WHAT I NOTICED?
THE SHELVES WERE FULL OF